with willingness there is possibility
your neighbor's Grass Is Always Greener
life is what you make of it
a good Marksman may miss
if an eel is with fish he shows his tail
if he is with snakes he shows his head
The Firm tree does not fear the storm
Still Waters Run Deep
a beautiful day A Gift To The Traveler
a person who loves their mother is doing
the best deed
Love is Like the Wind unseen but felt
every action has its consequence
different culture different customs
[Music]
a junior will always do what the senior
does
the shallower the brook the more it
babbles
there is no point of nurturing anger
inside us Let It Go
asking questions is the only way to
learn
there will be a replacement for
everything
[Music]
a long dispute has been forgotten by
love
but sometimes a long time of goodness
has been forgotten by one evil
[Music]
think through everything before
committing yourself this will prevent
later regrets
people tend to be attracted to what most
benefits them
like seaweed that clings to itself after
each passing boat separates it
so too a family will come together with
the passing of each crisis
if we practice we can succeed
an egotistic person can't see his own
mistakes but can always find mistakes in
others
[Music]
even things that are far apart can meet
as one
love doesn't need to have wings but it
should give freedom
[Music]
if there is smoke there must be fire
every why has its wherefore
nothing is perfect even the finest Ivory
has cracks
the fruit Falls near the tree
think through your idea first regrets
are useless
love is like a flower it needs to be
watered
a person will be remembered by his
accolades
the sea becomes the shore the shore
becomes the sea
every action has its consequences
be careful of what you say words can
hurt more than a knife
[Music]
each is dependent on the other for their
Mutual survival
no matter how stressed or angry we are
we have to solve a problem with logic
[Music]
when prominent persons fight commoners
suffer
wherever you step on the earth hold up
the sky
be careful when Falling in Love
rode the boat Upstream swim to the
riverbank endure hardships first then
enjoy life later
united we stand divided we fall
a drop of water in the ocean becomes the
ocean
love doesn't have to possess
a tiger leaves its stripes behind when
it dies an elephant leaves its ivory
[Music]
an elephant is invisible to the eye but
an ant across the ocean can be seen
when there is sugar there are ants
love comes from the eyes and goes down
to the heart
a sincere heart will attract another
heart
[Music]
a calm heart creates love
true love is patient
splashing water is not deep
when there's no Rattan Roots will do
stay away from the fire and you won't
get burned
when one door closes another opens
forced love is never happy
a tree with abundant fruit is sure to be
stoned
paddle Upstream swim to the shore
what seems impossible can become
possible
the help or kindness you provide today
may be returned in the future
love doesn't need to be heard but it
should be felt
when the path is open keep moving
forward
[Music]
the things we desire may be plentiful
elsewhere but scarce for us
calm water carries you away
love is like a flower it needs to be
watered
work is the source of all good
walls have ears doors have eyes
love is like fire it can illuminate or
burn
the sweetness of food doesn't last long
but the sweetness of good words does
[Music]
there is no other happiness but peace
love is like a bird if caged it will die
slow fires will smolder for a long time
[Music]
to a man wine is like water is to a boat
it can carry him or swallow him
you have to lose something to get
something else
hidden under Rags you may find gold
those who can't dance blame it on the
flute or the drum
friends for a meal are easy to find
friends for life are difficult to find
a virtuous person sleeps well
True Love Will Wait even if it takes a
long time
don't eat fruit before it is ripe
when the water rises hurry to get some
the cat is away the mouse is cheerful
love the older sister but yearn for the
younger one
live your best act your best think your
best each day for there may be no
tomorrow
the man who regards his own life and
that of his fellow creatures as
meaningless is not merely unfortunate
but almost disqualified for life
make sure the thing you were living for
is worth dying for
life is a flower of which love is the
honey
life is short and it's up to you to make
it sweet
we should employ our passions in the
service of life not spend life in the
service of our passions
life is not measured by length but by
depth birthdays tell us how long we have
been on the road not how far we have
traveled
what makes life dreary is absence of
motive
what makes life complicated is
multiplicity of motive what makes life
Victorious is singleness of motive
the meaning of life is to find your gift
the purpose of life is to give it away
never take for granted a quiet person he
may have qualities that belie his quiet
nature
when you look at an elephant look at its
tail when you look at a girl look at her
mother
beware the enemy lies under your blanket
it is not how long but how well we live
that matters
life is not measured by the number of
breaths we take but by the moments that
take our breath away
a person who talks a lot is usually
empty
The Seven Ages of man
spills drills Thrills bills ills pills
Wills
life is a journey that must be traveled
no matter how bad the road and
accommodations